so good afternoon everyone so I'm Oliver
and I'm a master student at the Benton
Center for computational neuroscience
and I've been working on my master's
thesis during the last few months and I
focus to find out where humans look in a
visual scene and I'm trying to build
models that would predict where humans
would look when they would explore a
visual scene and this our answer that
I'm trying to find during this talk
today and yeah so first of all why do we
need to care about this so just imagine
you want to find something in the
supermarket so you want to find a jar of
pickles and you you're on the
supermarket and you're like really over
well by all the massive a retinal input
that you receive and your brain is very
overwhelmed with all the data and like
all the thousands of products them like
millions of pixels so what do you do
luckily the brain has evolved into a
system that's able to give you something
like an attentional focus when you I'm
trying to solve a task so in this case
if you know what you are looking for
with time you will kind of focus on a
specific part and you see in but it will
guide you to fulfill your goal actually
and you I think you all know this
feeling that when you are like trying to
do something and you just have this like
moment of focus that you only think
about a certain part of your image at
the moment you try to like write a text
for example and this is this attentional
mechanism that I'm talking about so but
there are two different things so it can
contribute to your attention so there's
like this top-down view on attention
when that kind of takes place when you
try to solve a task so you're very
motivated to fulfill a goal and this
then drives you and motivates you to do
something but this is not always like
dependent on your image itself and this
is what I'm going to talk about the
second more bottom-up approach so these
inherent features that the visual scene
can have that then draw your attention
to certain part in the visual scene
and these are the things that I'm going
to talk about so how do we study human
gaze so what we can do is we can use eye
tracking so I tracking is this technique
that is able to record um your eyes and
reconstruct trajectories and fixations
and this gives you access to study where
humans are looking at and to analyze
this kind of data in the end and there's
like a I'm just giving you a brief on
summary I'm on a tracking research so it
started somehow in doctor 50s and 60s
and like one of the pioneers in eye
tracking was this person called Davos
and he kind of found out that when you
when we explore a visual scene what we
are seeing is very task-specific so it's
different when I'm asking you oh please
find out where this person on the left
here came from what's a background - for
example when you want to find out oh
what's the color of her eye for example
so there's independence on where you
look on the task in the step or
something new back then it is very
influenced in a very influential idea
somehow in the field and then later
psychologists and cognitive
neuroscientists started to focus more on
very basic mechanisms so they try to
find out what does evoke a high
attention in a certain region of a
visual scene and they kind of came up
with the studies that looked like this
oriented bars and as you can see there
or horizontal except for one which is
slightly oriented and they found that
it's very reliably when they I would
record eye tracking data from subjects
that most of the people almost all of
them would focus on this oriented
stimuli so this is somehow gives you an
idea of what is important for the visual
system such that you attend a certain
region because in this there's like some
information encoded in this orientation
that's not there in the rest of the
scene so this is this idea of a local
contrast being of important importance
here
um but yes since we kind of also want to
understand what humans process when they
are in a lot more natural setting
because these stimuli are very
artificial later people then again turn
to more natural scenes and for example
in the study budget and all they used
like the rather large data set and I
tracked a thousand participants while
they were viewing these these images and
with that we can now like look into
models and similar things but I tracking
sort on using research also industry has
been very active in this domain for
example if you would have designed a
webpage and you may want to make sure
that the user is looking at the part on
your webpage that you have liked that
you want to highlight and you can make
like a check with the eye tracking
device so you can give the webpage to
some users and you can see the way they
explore the scene and where they focus
and with that you can really try to make
sure that the user gets the content that
you want to use it to house and also
very importantly like it's a lot it's
used a lot in supermarket design so
companies are very interested in
designing their selling spaces in a way
such that they optimize the income of
course so they're very interested that
the consumer sees more pricey products
or products of a certain brand and with
eye tracking it's possible that they can
check for this and maybe rearrange their
products in a way that it's more optimal
for their desires so yeah this is this
so what visual features could be of
interest when we explore a visual scene
there's been like a lot of different
concepts that were proposed in the past
so one very intuitive idea so this is
the images I'm going to use as a sample
and to guide you through the different
concepts the color contrast is believed
to kind of draw like human
gays somehow because it locations where
there is like a change in color there
seems to be a region where something
interesting is happening or where you
should be alarmed or like yeah you can I
think it's quite intuitive then a second
and another very low level I'm concept
its orientation contrast I think it
already motivated with the oriented bar
before but also here so at locations
where the orientation or like the edges
in image somehow change these are
regions that the visual system might be
interested in because like all complex
shapes are somehow formed from
orientations and also when you think
about text text is basically just a
collection of different edges oriented
differently so these are two very
low-level
ideas about what could be of importance
to the visual system when we talk about
where humans focus then more like in a
more high-level perspective you can say
that faces the objects could be the most
important things because humans want to
interact with there is a real world and
for these faces are of importance in
this case it's a Penguin's faces also of
course objects because objects give us a
lot of opportunities to interact with
the world so this would be somehow very
intuitive and also um I think you would
agree that this is these are things that
you focus on when you explore a visual
scene and then as a special case this
also proposed like especially human
faces are very important for drawing
your attention because already as a
child we learn ok the faces my mother is
very important to me because they she
feeds me and she kind of helps me to
manage my life and to develop and so
this would be also like a very likely
candidate so now looking at some
experimental results so these are like
data points that were collected from an
eye tracking study so we see basically
that the observer focuses on the
Penguins faces mostly but also on the
camera in the background a bit more and
also on the human face in the background
but there's still like a lot of noise as
well and some exploration in the
fixations so from this kind of data
along it's very hard to find what are
the important features in the end that
contribute to to drawing our attention
so yeah already with the beginning of
like this research in this area people
were already quite interested in finding
models as well because models might
solve this problem because they give us
a way to better understand how this data
was generated and so when we want to for
example frame a model we could think of
it like that so we have an input image
and we there's a mysterious processing
going on
represented here by this black box and
in the end we come up with a CNC map and
this idea of a saline sea map is very
interesting so is everyone familiar with
the terms agency or who's not familiar
with it
okay very good so um salience is just
this idea of evoking a high attentional
response from you so for example when
you are looking at this senior at the
moment you are you're when your
attention is like focus on me or the
screen there's other regions where
salience is very high in a visual scene
so salience ii i captures where you kind
of direct your attention to and it's not
only you're in visual input but salience
it also applies to other domains for
example in sound when you are listening
to a tune you somehow kind of have these
moments that you are very focused on a
specific and know like a beat kicks in
or something and this is them that
you're a moment where you have a high
salience ii so somehow like i'm linked
to a high probability of really being
very conscious about what you are
experiencing and this idea of s agency
map is very neat because this agency map
is basically a 2d probability density
over your input image in this case which
tells you that at regions with the high
probability density
you have a heist agency so these are
regions where you are very likely to
attend to so in this in this example
this would be mainly the faces again of
these performers and yeah so this seems
to be most important and this this map
was constructed from AI fixations so how
do we come up with a model in this case
now so all that we have is like an input
image and we have the fixations that we
get from eye tracking and with this
setting we now try to find a model that
can somehow shed some light on this
blackbox scenario and since I am NOT the
first person to think about this there's
a zoo of models in this comparative
study here by Kimmel right owl and they
compare like a lot of like very classic
models that were proposed in the past
and just to kind of make sure you
understand how I'm presenting this here
so the gold standard you can see here
it's the perfect model so what we are
measuring here is information gain
explained so it's basically just how
much information are we able to explain
with our model given our fixation so the
fixations are recorded and now we try to
find out how much of these recorded
fixations can we explain with our model
and this gold standard
is our reference so it's like all the
fixations that we recorded so this has I
could explains a hundred percent so all
of the information and you could see
this as like the brain model because the
brain somehow generated the fixations
that we record it and in the end and now
looking at all the other models we can
first of all see that not like there's
really not a lot of models that are very
good at this task so at most we reach
performance of like 33 percent so
there's still like a lot of improvement
to be done to really have a good model
for this task and one of the oldest
model that was proposed of one of the
very classic models is it in cost model
and what they use is they only use very
low level information so they make use
of color contrast they make use of
orientation contrast so they take edges
and they look at intensity contrast and
they use
features to predict this agency map in
the end so it's only very like basic
information but there's been like always
a very strong debate about what kind of
draws our attention is it more like
low-level information like do we look at
light mainly or do we all like attend
like edges and our like gaze follows an
edge only or is it like color that
mainly draws our attention or is it more
like this high-level concepts are we
mainly looking like objects at faces at
people and these kind of things and
these kind of models here so more to the
left we have these low-level models and
then the more we move to the right
people try to include more high-level
information so for example in this job
model here they use like handcrafted
face detectors to incorporate high-level
features but it's not so easy to include
its high-level features because you
would need like an object extractor for
every possible object in the world so
it's not so easy but luckily we are in
the type of deep learning so what you
can make use of as you can use and
filters that were pre trained on the
object classification tasks and use
these like filters to extract features
that you would use them for sailing tea
predictions of this idea of transfer
learning there is applied here and with
these type of models saliency
performance is really boosted so now we
actually have models that are quite good
at capturing our experimental data and
like in the following and the rest of
the talk I'm going to like go deeper
into this debate about low versus high
level and I try to come up with like a
new low level model because what's very
interesting is that more recently people
found a new low level model which I'm
showing here so it only uses intensity
information it's the intensity contrast
feature model and it outperforms all of
the older models even these that
included high level like faces and these
kinds of things so again can shifted the
whole debate on like low versus high
level
features and change like a and
considered to hold discussion up again
so what I'm trying to find out again and
what was a part of my master thesis
basically is to find the features that
drive salience see there's like main
motivation but then also I try to
disentangle like how much information
can be explained by low levels that's
high level information and then also I'm
trying to come up with a new model which
which we can further reduce this
performance gap between the Steve Case
model using object classification deep
features and the simple intensity
features yeah so looking at methods I'm
going to introduce the architecture that
we are using and it looks like this so
we have an input image and what we do
first is we want to extract features of
course so um for now we just think of it
as a black box again so we have some
feature extraction algorithm which which
then gives us a set of feature Maps and
then since we have a set of feature maps
we now need to somehow reduce the
dimensionality because we want to have
like one probability density over our
image such that we can say okay this is
a region of high probability and in
order to do that we propose a readout
network and this weeded network
recombines these feature maps it's a
four layer convolutional network and we
end up with the raw salience in map here
in this volatility map is then blurred
so it's very extended saliency research
processing them and you can add tasks of
specific buyers because what has been
found over the decades is that people
tend to focus on the center of the
visual field and neglect what's at the
boundaries so you can include this
already as a bias in your models such
that your model doesn't need to learn it
like a heavy lifted on a by itself and
then since we are interested in the
probability density we apply a soft max
to end up with a probability density so
that's the basic architecture I hope I
explained it
clearly if not let me know so now next
we need some models which which with
which we can extract features the first
of all I'm again showing the intensity
contrast feature model and what what we
are doing here basically is just
blurring the image with different a blur
kernel so it's like gaussians of
different sizes and we just apply them
in a convolutional way and just blur the
image with different sizes so these are
like the first features that we're using
and then second we use also and
something like all the variance features
which is the difference between the
image before blurring and after blurring
and this again gives us interesting
properties and has been found to be
beneficial for predicting salient theme
this is the first very low level model
it's quite surprising actually that it
works so well then as a second model we
proposed this garble model so it's a set
of these edge detectors that are
parametrized so during training we do
not only learn the parameters in the
readout Network but also the parameters
of our galvo model and this is just some
examples so what these features these
filters do is they extract an edge as a
different orientation and we then use
these resulting features to again as an
input to the readout network which are
then used for prediction of this agency
map so these were both like low-level
models and then again as the high-level
model I am showing here the DK smaller
which was like the best model very much
to the right before and yeah I'm just
showing like a few of these like very
high level features so I think you've
all seen them probably it's very like
specific very high level information and
very object specific and OOP and it's
not only like these few filters but it's
actually like two and a half thousand
features that we are extracting from
convolutional layer 5 from an VG g19
that we train on the image not image net
task so then of course we end up with a
very large number of future maps it's
like two and a half thousand feature
maps that we then use so this kind of
setting has a lot of more parameters in
the end which also has the problem that
we don't really understand of what is
important in the end with the previous
models we knew okay we are using edges
or we are using like intensity values
but here like we have two and half
thousand features and we don't really
know okay is it like this filter that
encodes a gorilla for example that was
important for this scene or is it more
feature that encodes for like some
specific structure capturing like leaves
on the floor or something like this
that's very like unclear and what the
model does but it does it very well okay
so now we need to train our model of
course and insurgency we are very much
confronted it with the problem that I
tracking is very costly I'm not sure if
you have participated but it's kind of
very like how to somehow to sit there to
look at images to record the data and
then since we train like deep networks
here we need to have a large amount of
data and to solve this problem luckily
there's this data set called Sally
comment what people found here is they
use an approximation to eye tracking
basically so it's not eye tracking
experiments that they conducted but they
conducted something more simple and it's
called Mouse tracking so they just show
images to subject in like Amazon
Mechanical Turk setting and people which
were just asked to explore the visual
scene with their mouth striking and at
the position where the mouse would be at
a certain moment in time this image
would become more clear than and they
found it is very nicely correlate with
the actual eye tracking data so this
kind of data is not what we actually are
interested in but we can use as an
approximation and then to like this is
views for pre-training and then for
fine-tuning we use an actual saline CI
tracking data set so you can see the
fixations look slightly different but
they still correlate
and yeah the thousand images only so it
wouldn't be sufficient to train the full
network using only these but for
fine-tuning it's enough and the old both
of these datasets consist of natural
scenes so it's very like a widespread
photos of like food and people and
parties and very funny actually to go
through them so I highly recommend it
and on this test data set here or DJ
material said that also some of these
very artificial stimuli that I talked
about before so next then we need to
train our network and for this we use
this pipeline so first of all we need to
train our between our parameters using
this like approximated datasets Alacran
and we stopped the training as soon as
the performance on our evaluation data
set decreases and with these parameters
we then initialize our fine-tuning which
we do in a five-fold cross validated
manner so we always leave one set out
and use it for testing afterwards and
then the last function be applying is
basically just the maximum likelihood
estimator so we want to optimize our
parameters such that they best capture
the experimentally observed data and so
this is just the sum of all the images
of the log-likelihood function and this
probability here this P of X Y given I
is what our model outputs so this is the
sailing see map basically okay so now
finally to some results so first of all
and the way I'm presenting the results
so what we are looking at here is the
scale is a bit perfect ation so it's
some kind of measure of how much
information can we explain so again we
have as an upper bound to add the
performance that we can expect is this
experimental gold standard size this is
the model which could explain all what
we observed experimentally what we could
explain experimentally so that at about
2.1 bits per fixation and then as a
lower bound
we use a model which is not really a
model but it's only applying the center
bias so this model only predicts the
center bias for every image it doesn't
really care what image it sees it always
predicts the same and already with the
simple setting we capture quite some
information in our data and it's about
it like point nine bits per fixation and
then yeah first of all I reproduce the
results so this intensity model and this
deep case model set somehow like the
lower and higher bounded I'm exploring
in-between and I did this with the
proposed garble models from before so
intensity colors again it's the low
level model which uses very simple
features and the deep case model it's a
very high level object focused model so
the garble model we now actually could
show that it kind of again decreases
this gap in between high and low level
models so using orientation is very
beneficial actually for predicting where
humans attempted in a visual scene so
this is quite nice so this again kind of
brings evidence for the importance of
low level information and kind of
decreases some of the very big influence
of high level information and then I
think quite intuitively as the next step
we tested combining both low level
models to see if intensity and
orientation would further improve
performance but we found that this is
not the case so this is interesting in a
way because it suggests that the Garbo
model approximates these intendancy
features during training
so it basically the Garbo model is the
best we can do at the moment with it
work if we only want to use low level
information elects so now I think now
that you've made it through this like
slightly statistical part I'm actually
sure going to show you the prediction
that all models are making so on the
Left I'm showing you the input image
that we see that in into dinner at the
model and then from
- right I am presenting the results for
the eating course models it was this
very early first CNC model then there's
this intensity model II ICF then the
Garbo model and - very right there's a
decays model and the higher this number
here is again this pitch-perfect session
so how much information can be explained
so the higher this number the better
this is the first of all looking at this
face so this is in red we see the
experimental the observed data and then
as we go through the model we see first
of all that this 18 cross model is quite
bad at doing this task which is a bit
sad because there somehow does the
founding fathers of the whole field but
it is what it is and then looking at the
other models they all seem to perform
similarly although they focus on
different regions of the image so when
we see this very like the blue regions
this is where the model predicts a high
probability of you looking at this image
whereas the yellow region seem to be
unimportant to us now another example
this you've seen before and now I'm
comparing it here so deep case is very
good at only focusing on these of these
phases and thereby actually captures
what is observed in real experiments
where is the other models especially
Garbo intensity focus way too much I
like the color contrast in their
wardrobe and they also overestimate
generally like arm is like light spots
that are on this shiny belt here and so
yeah only D place is really a belay
mental and results here another example
and this is one nice example where the
Garbo model actually is best so we found
that the government is really good at
picking up likes perspective so we found
it when we look at an image with a
perspective we tend to like look along
the visual axis and this is something
that the garbha mode is very good at
capturing wears deep case here only
focuses on the Exodus and bike
pedestrians walking on the sidewalk and
there's some text on this building but
really captured it's like looking along
a nexus I think you have all experiences
somehow and again Etienne Cox is
unfortunately quite bad then like one of
these very artificial stimuli they were
very important for the development of
the field so here actually it being
caused isn't the worst model for once
it's the second worst only it's great
and this is mainly the case because it
being caused were motivated by these
artificial stimuli when they designed
their model and all the other models
seem to be way better at capturing
natural images so this is another import
the inside here and yet this is
basically all the predictions I wanted
to show you so with my summary I want to
kind of reach make sure that you
understand that humans tend to look at
faces at text and at objects but they
also focus a lot like low-level feature
contrasts so at color contrast at
orientation contrast you started in a
stimuli before and also add intensity
contrast so we do look at lights and
then second salience II seems to be
driven both by high and low level
features which is also quite interesting
because people really believe that you
could explain most of it by either one
or the other and really if you want to I
kind of make use of like this predictive
agency models these classic models
perform quite poorly so if you are
actually interested in making some good
predictor predictions for your use case
you should think about using these more
recent models
unlike deep case for example and yeah
with that so if you want to get more
into the fields I kind of put the
sources here and also some links so on
this webpage here you can upload your
own images and see what are the salient
regions you can like check your
Instagram photos before you upload if
they are focusing on the right spots so
there's like a tool box as well that you
can make use of this is from a
supervisor and I also am uploading my
coat on but it's still work-in-progress
and so yeah
all I wanted to tell you thanks for
listening and yeah please ask me
anything you want to all right thank you
very much any questions yeah thanks for
the great talk
I actually have two questions and that's
okay feel free so the first one is
because you showed that DK is actually
not very good with his perspective
images yeah were they part of the
training set of D psi yeah okay cool so
I could be heard like pretty much
they're like I think eight to ten
different classes but they are all part
both training and testing okay so it
actually should know that yeah but yeah
just it's in the juices like these
filters from object classification
Network it doesn't get like I think no
class perspective or like hack and look
along a street or something maybe like
in streets I'm not sure if there's AG
labeled object Street in the data set I
don't know I I don't know this question
now just popped into my hat what
happened for instance if you don't look
like at the whole salience a map but
let's say this alien see map of the
first couple of 10 20 milliseconds then
maybe they're low-level features are
more important it's like the brain
processing of like faces and everything
didn't kick in yet is that very well
robust there this is indeed the case so
I'm actually this low level like
intensity these ICS model we tested at
least is way better in the early like
first it's 100 to 200 milliseconds and
then later decays takes over we did find
that thanks
I think for the talk if I understood
correctly you are using this deep gaze
issues and a pre-trained at work on its
pretty not an object recognition right
that just with a couple of image we
showed I had the impression that it's a
bit may be biased by high-level like in
the in the for the face and for the this
picture with the performers and it hasit
so I have the my question is have you
have you drive like training and network
from scratch with the with this with the
input data to compare with the with the
ITF and grabber the problem is that the
three doesn't converge because it's like
yeah we have like 10,000 images for
pre-training under thousandfold testings
like eleven thousand samples and it's
not enough like to train a network from
scratch I think what people have
proposed is to use like random filters
and this kind of suggests random
initializing convolutional filters and
then seeing if they pick up some
structure in your input images but it
didn't seem to work too well so it's
still yeah D plays outperformed him by
large margin so yeah it's a problem
because I the data that we are the riff
access to is very limited so we are we
still I think if we would have more data
it would be possible probably to do that
I thought for example also about like
maybe just put on like I think by now we
do have these i fixation goggles that we
could walk around with I guess and just
use them somehow as the input and then
train a network from scratch by using
these fixations that you can record at
the same time I think this could be a
way to do that because then we have like
unlimited training cases basically yeah
I could be I was very like something
like the domination or there's also like
tell you like there is a new dataset
published in Nature Neuroscience from
the University of a snippet that
released a recent job and ever yeah we
haven't introduced include ammonia or
something exactly yeah my impression is
that it would be possible to
to have better results training a
network from scratch that is not biased
by by a abstract clinician Network
because I think this is also a way I
guess we went like a baby learns to
understand what an object is
I guess they first need to like look at
the object and then learn the label
somehow yeah so this kind of seems more
natural as well yeah I agree on that but
it's not possible yet so thank you
No
we didn't specifically include like
webpages it's not like what I think we
are we're interested in but you could of
course do that but you would need to
have like the I fixation as well so if
you want to train your Moll you always
need like the input image and also like
fixations from some study so I guess if
you would have that then it's like quite
easy I think I haven't checked actually
I I guess so when there are these kind
of things then people do it for their
own company and probably don't really
release it as not sure if anyone knows
of them please let me know but I haven't
haven't found any thank you
could use your metamodel which takes the
three and trained em a linear
combination and then maybe improve even
more elastic media we've been discussing
that actually would be quite nice and
the only thing I did so far it's like
combining the deep gaze features with
the in tendency features but it didn't
really improve performance somehow so I
guess it's mainly because GPS also
learns to approximate these low-level
things at some point from high-level
features but yeah it's really hard to
get that out of the model in the end but
how to disentangle thank you
[Applause]